완전 멋있는 공간으로 바뀌었습니다
그래서 여기는 진짜 말도 안 되는
뷰입니다
뭔가 세상을 다 가진듯한 그런
느낌인데
[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌 사람입니다 제가
연남동
랜드마크 리모델링 현장에 와 있는데
사실 제가 영상을 최근에 찍었었어요
찍었는데 그 영상이 다 날라갔어요
그래서
진짜 포기할까 하다가 아 이거는
무조건 찍어야 된다라고 해서
처갓집에 있다가 횡성에 있다가
급히 아침 6시에 올라왔습니다
여러분들한테 이거는 꼭 보여드려야
된다라고 생각을 해가지고 지금 이렇게
영상을 찍게 됐습니다 그 전 영상에서
보셨을 거예요
리모델링 하기 전 모습도 좀 담았고
그 다음에 현수막도 건 그런 영상도
있는데 한번 찾아가서 그 전 영상도
보셔도 좋을 것 같아요 그랬던 건물이
지금
뒤에 보시는이 건물로 정말 말도 안
되게 변했습니다
외관도
진짜
완전
완전 이거 완전 신축 같아요 소장님
일단은 좀
외관은 좀 어떻게 변했는지 좀
간단하게 설명 좀 부탁드리겠습니다
어쨌든 기존의 화강석으로 마감이 되어
있었던 건물이었고요
우선 건물주께서 사실은 일부
리모델링을 하셨어요
저희하고는 좀 색깔이 맞지 않는 그런
티가 안 나게 디자인이었어 가지고
그런 부분들을 계산하기를 저희가
공사를 시작하기 전에 이미 이제 저
친구의 임차인이 결정이 됐죠 그래서
그 부분이 사실 굉장히 고민이
많았어요 그래서 저층부하고 고층부가
나눠서 보여야 되고 또 어떤 면에서는
또 통일성이 있어야 되고 이런
부분들을 상승되는 부분을 맞추는게 좀
그런 과정들이 어려웠는데 사실은 조금
더 기간을 가지고서는 디자인 작업을
했으면
하는 바램이 있었는데 일정에 맞춰서
보니까
그렇게 많은 시간을 또 소유할 수
없었고 어느 정도 절충을 한게 저층도
하고 고층부에 대한 재료를 통일을
하고
색상을 좀 맞춰 가지고 건물의
전체적인 통일성을
가지게끔
그렇게 디자인을 하고 대신에 저
승부하고 이제 상승부에 대해서
부분적으로 좀 차별화될 수 있는
요소들이 적용을 해보자
그렇게 해서 이제 좀 디자인의 방향을
잡게 됐습니다 그래서 사실 보시면
저층부하고 상층부 고층부가 다 롱부리
타일을 썼는데
크기가 달라요
색상도 약간 달라요 사이즈가 지금
다르고
색상 유산
타입으로 보여지게끔 하기 위해서 좀
그렇게 재료들을 선정을 했습니다이
건물은 리모델링 하고 나서 진짜 완전
랜드마크 건물
됐고 그리고 지금 평일인데 사람이
너무 많아요 지금 아니 어떻게 이렇게
많이
시간대에도 유동인구가 굉장히 많고요
이게 저녁 시간이 되면은 더 많아져요
그리고 주말에는 더더욱 많습니다
정말 위치가 좋은 곳에 그런 낡았던
건물을 이렇게 멋지게
리모델링한 사례라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다 그래서 한번 내부로 들어가서
한번 자세히 보도록 하시죠
기존에는 엘리베이터가 7층까지
연장되지 않았어요 이번에 이제
리모델링을 하면서
엘리베이터를 7층까지 운행되도록
아마 기억나실 거예요 예전 영상에
딱 저희가 빈 박을 때 왔었던 것
같아요
완전 멋있는 공간으로 바뀌었습니다
그래서 여기는 진짜 말도 안 되는
뷰입니다
뭔가 세상을 다 가진듯한 그런
느낌인데 여기 이제
경의선 숲길이 너무 잘 보여요이
경의선 숲길에서 가장 큰 건물이기
때문에 이쪽 뷰가 너무 환상적인 것
같아요
[음악]
대신에 이제 이런 외부 공간이 있어서
활용하시기에는 사실 더 좋을 수도
있어요
그러니까 이런 거 좋아하는 임차인분들
되게 많거든요
저는
진짜 여기를 잘 한 거 같아요 지금
이게
6층까지 이렇게 연결이 돼 있어요
그래서 지금 여기를 크게 뚫어놨습니다
뒷부분이 다 이제 오픈이 되어 있는
가격인 거죠 그래서 여기도 뷰가 너무
좋아요요 느낌도 너무 좋고 저는요
느낌도 너무 좋고요 느낌도 좋고
한 면이 다 개방되어 있어서 어느
쪽으로든 선택하셔서
감상하실 수 있는 뷰가 나올 것
같아요네 그리고 6층에 가려고 하는데
공용공간은 또 이렇게
뚫어놨어요
엘리베이터 홀이랑 계단실 일부에 이제
전체적으로 측면한 부분에
창호를 다 계획을 해서 채광이
가능하게끔 이렇게 배치가 되어
있습니다
그러니까 이거는 진짜 잘하셨어요
이게 사실 없다고 생각하면 되게 뭐랄
폐쇄적인 공간 느낌 나거든요 근데
진짜 이게이 꼬꼬가 또 차이가 큰 거
같아요
6층의 경우에는 사실 기존에 이제
주택으로
쓰이던 부분이었고이 부분은 이제 그런
생각 시설로 변경을 하면서
서비스 발코니
부분이 남아 있었어요 그래서 이제
서비스 발코니 구간하고 내부 전용
공간하고를 구획을 해주는 이런
벽체와 창호가 설치가 돼야 됐던
상황이었습니다
여기가 예전에 그냥 주택일 땐 쓰던
거였잖아요요 공간도 되게 재밌는데요
공간도 되게 재밌네요
저기까지 연결이 되어 있었죠
그리고 대망의 제가 아까 말씀드렸던
이게 진짜 층마다 뷰가 좀 색다른 거
같아요 여기도 또 느낌이 좀 다른 거
같아요 이게 사실 우리
뒷부분에 이렇게 오픈된 가벽 구간이
한층에서 한 눈에 다 담기지는 않아요
근데 이제 6층하고 7층에서 봤을 때
이제 전체적인 하나의 프레임으로 좀
읽히게끔 좀 고려를 해서 이제 만든
부분이었는데
액자의 역할을 하는 그런 느낌을 담아
가지고 좀 계획을 했던 부분이
있었어요
그러니까 이거 진짜 돈 주고 살 수
없는 그런 액자라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다
한눈에 좀 당기지 않을만큼 좀 큰
스케일감이 익혀졌으면 좋겠다 왜냐하면
6층부터 지금 옥상까지 가격으로 쭉
연장이 되어 있는 공간이잖아요
그렇다 보니까 좀 큰 공간에는 또 큰
스케일의 그런 오프닝
구간이 있었으면 좋겠다 싶어서
그렇게 이제 배치를 했습니다
진짜 이게 이렇게 연결되어 있으니까
이게 규모가 진짜 엄청 큰 거 같아요
나중에 이제 밖에서 또이 건물을 봤을
때 이게 또
다른
뒤쪽으로 이제 나가 보시면은
와 이거 진짜
진짜 엄청 커 보인다
공간 안에 이렇게 쌓여 있는듯한
위로감을 우리가 준다고 하거든요
둘러 쌓여져 있는듯한 느낌을 줄 수
있는 공간이 이렇게
외부 공간으로 구성을 해 본 거죠
아 여기도 잘 뚫었네요
연희동까지 보이네요
여기도 이제 창을 냈죠
여기는 아까 저희가 그
발코니 부분 거기를 그냥 이제 다
쓴다라고 보시면 될 것 같아요 그래서
여기가 면적이 더 큰 거 같아요
그리고 이제 창업을 아무래도 이제
바닥에서부터 또 천장까지
연장되는 큰 형태의 창으로 계획을
하다 보니까 더 가까이 있는듯한
느낌이 드시고 이게 보통 이렇게
있잖아요 그런
부분 없이 지금
적용이 되어 있습니다네 그래서 저희가
마지막으로
지하층이 좀 내려왔는데
환기시설을 다 설치했네요
원래 기존에 이제 환기시설이 설치가
되어 있었던 상황이었고요 그것들을 좀
더 효과적으로 사용을 하기 위해서
설비를
추가를 했어요 지금 보이시는이 덕트가
이제 그런 역할을 해 줄 거고
송출소 쪽에는 이제 팬을 별도로
설치를 해서
원활하게 이루어질 수 있도록
그렇게 설계를 반영을 했습니다
그 전에도 와봤을 때는 사실 거의 뭐
약간 악취도 났었고 했는데
딱 그 공사하고 지금 와보니까 막
치나 이런 거 습한 건 없어진 거야
비상계단이 있어야 됩니다 그래서 그게
몇 제곱미터였죠
지자층 면접
50제곱미터가 있어야 되는데요 부분은
이제 좀 더
후반 작업을 통해서
들어올 수 있는 직접적인
출입구가 되니까
맞아요네 그래서 여러분들 리모델링
하실 때요 비상
출입구를 좀 꾸미면
지하 임차인이 잘 들어온다 그리고
사람들도 여기서 바로 들어오면 되니까
그런 부분을 좀 포인트로 기억하셨으면
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 우리가
다중이용 업소가 들어올 수 있도록
고려를 해서 지금 간이 스프링클러
시스템이 설치가 되어 있어요 그리고
지금 상부에 다 스프링클 사람들이
설치가 되어 있는 상황이고요 그래서
어떤 업종이 들어와도
스프링쿨러 설비도 있고
환계 설비도 있고
기상 재단까지 편한거가 2개소 확보가
되니까
어떤 용도로든 활용이 가능하십니다
그래서 저희 그
리모델링 사례를 봤는데
정말 저희 프로젝트 했던 거 중에
진짜 손꼽힐 정도로 너무 잘 된 거
같아요 그래서 여러분들도 나중에
연남동 오실리 있다라고 하면은
지나가다 한번 들리셔도 좋을 것
같습니다 여기 이제 커피숍 오픈하면
그쪽으로 오셔도 될 것 같아요 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다